Joker is the best player in the league
he's playing great here comes the
two-time MVP and they're on there
[Applause]
a guard in a big man's body oh wow
that's not a joke it's a Joker Joker
drop steps Banks it in they leave him
dare him to shoot and
open games he is pure basketball poetry
yogic lets him fly Brian I'm running out
of things to say about jokic
was there a moment when you said to
yourself I can really be effective in
this league
I don't know because I still don't
believe it that I can be effective you
know for me still every game is a fight
and uh that's why I like my my teammates
in college they really trust me and uh
reach the trust that we have and the
relationship I think it's really good it
will gonna help us help us win games so
I know you don't like all the awards and
all the individual accolades but when
you win two consecutive MVPs and you're
in the conversation for a third you
still don't believe that you're among
the best basketball players in this
league I mean I don't believe that uh
because I don't want to think about the
problem that way I'm just trying to win
the game and that's that's my main focus
well when I finish my career when I stop
playing and then a couple years after
like probably I'm gonna see the trophies
or see whatever maybe then but remember
I know I don't have time for this
Murray moving beautifully hits again
Murray taking him to the schoolyard some
more Murray magic then it's looking
Murray throwing a Haymaker he is just an
obliterating the Lakers let's talk about
Jamal
the adversity he's gone through how much
more special do you think this playoff
run has meant because of that I mean I
never have been injured so in fighting
through injury he didn't play basically
one and a half year and just to come
back and uh we're doing the beginning of
the season I told everybody she's going
to be really bad for 20 30 games but uh
after let's say All-Star break he's
playing on a really high level and you
see the the last series against Lakers
he was really really good our leader in
uh he was he was going the ball really
well his energy was amazing and he's a
really good a really good basketball
player
Pope knocks down a three of course it
goes in here comes Morris
it's over it's over
Denver makes history the nuggets are
going to the NBA finals for the first
time in franchise history
how special is it that this is the first
time I mean of course it's nice just
because never not even one team done it
before but there are some good teams
that play for the nuggets and good
players and I think that just shows how
hard it's to get here we made the
history okay but I think we are not
satisfied we want something more
what was the biggest challenge Miami
provides they never quit they were
playing the same way they're aggressive
on the both sides of the floor they
never stop they never they always keep
coming you know gonna be the hardest
games of our lives and we'll prepare for
that